in a stunning display of hypocrisy
President Biden reversed course on the
border wall this week I can't wait to
hear the Build That Wall chant at the
Biden rallies if they have them with my
orcus admitting quote there is presently
an acute and immediate need to construct
physical barriers and yesterday
President Biden insisted that when it
comes to funding the border wall legally
his hands are tied money was
appropriated for the border wall I tried
to get reappropriate to redirect that
money they didn't they wouldn't and in
the meantime there's nothing under the
law other than they have to use the
money for what appropriate I can't stop
that he left none other than press
secretary Karen John Pierre to drive
home the message risky and she sure did
because she appeared to have just one
talking point in her
binder we're complying by the law we
have to comply by the law we have to
comply by the law as we have to comply
by the law we have to comply by the law
we have to comply by law to get this
done you want us to break the law is
that what you want you want us to not
comply with the law we have to comply by
the law we're following the law here
it's as simple as that we are following
the law those were all separate unique
times and there were more but wait when
she was pressed on exactly what law they
were complying with she didn't have an
answer what specific law would the
administration be breaking if funds
appropriated for the border wall are not
used well look I'm not going to speak to
uh the law I would have to refer you to
Department of Justice I'm not a lawyer
when you go to the doj to get the answer
for the Press joining me now is Chad
wolf former acting DHS secretary during
the Trump Administration Chad what did
you think when your successor my orcus
all of a sudden found an acute need for
the very wall you were trying to build
alongside former president
Trump well uh Kelly it's a stunning
reversal uh and I think it's an
embarrassment for this Administration
they spent the the last three years
trying to convince the American people
that the wall is ineffective that it's
bigoted it's racist and all the other
terms that they they called the wall at
the end of the day just to address the
point you know it's one thing for
Congress to pass a law to say that you
must use these funds to build a wall
that's fine we know the Biden
Administration really doesn't care what
Congress thinks but what what the
Congress doesn't tell you to do is to
wave 26 environmental laws like they did
like secretary my orcus did and put that
in a Federal Register notice six pages
to say an acute and immediate need to
build border wall in South Texas and
then try to tell the American people his
his comments and his words were taken
out of context no one took them out of
context they're in the Federal Register
it's very clear what their need is and
they site the August apprehension
numbers along the border as proof to
that they need to wave these
environmental laws so look they're
they're trying to have it both ways they
say they're not a fan of the wall but
then secretary my orcus is trying to
build the wall as quickly as he can and
for an Administration that's so keen on
you know we enforce the law we comply
with the law we don't want to break the
law it seems to me there is a law
against illegally entering the country
and they're breaking that law every
day every single day every single day
they're not enforcing immigration law
and border security law along that
border not letting ice agents do their
job and to remove individuals I think
it's been pretty clear and documented
the unlawful acts such as paroling
individuals into the country
that this Administration has done over
the last 2 and a half years and look the
list goes on and on and on uh it's clear
that this administration's border
security strategy also is a complete and
utter failure and you just have to look
at whether they're trying to build
border wall they're paroling individuals
in they're trying to remove Venezuelans
it's all over the map there is no Rhyme
or Reason to their strategy and and it's
like we've got the junior varsity team
on the playing field and they're having
and they're really struggling on what to
do well I'm just glad KJ P lost the
talking point about heavy winds causing
walls to be in effective that one that
one wasn't passing the smell test Chad I
wish you were still in that role maybe
you'll be in it again thank you very
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else